hey guys it is the 24th of March my name
is Jess McDonald and you're watching
games but news feel free to play along
at home and let us know how you go EA
has been pushing some of your buttons a
little bit today by saying that when
they do get something a little bit wrong
they do their best to fix it some of you
respectfully disagreed EA CEO Andrew
Wilson has been discussing a number of
issues the publisher has faced as well
as its future with the new console
generation referring to the SimCity
debacle of last year Wilson said that
even though they don't always get
everything right he still thinks EA is
seen as a company that tries to do
amazing things do you think EA will be
able to work their way back into gamers
favor and how are they going to do it
next up insane people did insane things
and it's all vaguely related to video
games said insane person was a 19 year
old Utah man who was asked by his
stepfather to stop playing video games
after refusing his stepfather shut off
the console himself while his son was
mid game so naturally the gamer Alec
young understood why his console needed
to be shut off it went on to have a
great video game less evening no that
would be a horrible story what did
happen was that young started screaming
and throwing remotes at his stepfather
before stabbing the stepfathers murder
bike with a knife and then ramming it
into the wall of the garage with his car
causing about 25 grand in damage
sensible next up for something that's
actually about video games a watchdogs
dev has said that the ps4 is so powerful
that it and i quote gave us a chance to
dream it's nice that nobody's
overdramatizing anything today according
to watch dogs animation director Colin
gray in the console has an almost
unlimited memory budget which is a huge
asset for any animation team Graham says
that from an animation point of view
they're always running out of memory
particularly when they start developing
toward the end of a console generation
so the ps4 allowed things like reduced
animation compression and more variety
in civilians just to be clear nothing
negative was said about the xbox one in
this interview which took place on
PlayStation Blog it was strictly to
discuss how the game plays on Sony's
console let me know what platform your
watchdogs experience
going to take place on either in that
comment section down below or you can do
so on my Twitter where I'm at just mcdon
speaking of which thank you very much
within in all your pictures of you
watching GS news they are all awesome
those are all the things that I have to
tell you today but I've got four more
big news episodes for the rest of the
week so be sure to join me for the
second same time tomorrow